um hi everybody my name is Abe and I
recently released a Python package
called high score and I'm going to talk
to you about that tonight before I get
started I wanted to thank bum tech for
hosting I can't say enough good things
about thumbtack really great exciting
company and I know they're hiring data
scientists machine learning people so if
you're interested yeah you should
definitely shoot the mountain
application because they are great and
they are totally killing it so good work
phone back um so I think it's important
to when I started here to discuss what I
actually mean by scores it's kind of a
loaded term with lots of definitions and
so the score is I'm talking about that
you can make the high score are like
walkscore recently acquired by red pen
that allows you to input an address and
i'll tell you how walkable your
neighborhood is or clout recently
acquired by lithium clout take social
media profiles and maps them somewhat
nonsensically the scores between 1-100
Barack Obama gets a 99 short but it's
not just recently acquired startups that
can use scores the NFL has the
quarterback passer rating that's a nice
plot there and then mitre has the common
weakness scoring system which is used to
assess software vulnerabilities so
scores come up a lot and high score is a
python package that can help you make
and maintain scoring functions and there
are two real advances here and one is
kind of on the philosophical side and
the second is on the algorithmic side so
I'm going to talk about both of those
advances here and so the philosophical
side is called supervised scoring which
is a new way of actually just thinking
about how you construct a score
so let's like zoom out of rena start
talking about philosophies like what our
scores like how would you describe what
is happening when you score something
and the best definition of come up with
is that scores are a tool for domain
experts to communicate their expertise
to a broad audience so you're taking a
complex notion that may be largely
unintelligible to a layperson and you're
saying look I'm the expert I can tell
you this weird kind of they usually
orange blob on the left is an 88 where
is that kind of weird greenish blob on
the right is only 227 so to laypeople
it's kind of mysterious as to why the
scores are that way but the expert can
use their discretion to come up with
reasonable scores that can communicate
their expertise to a broad audience
another way of looking at it that maybe
is a Moore machine learning centric way
is as a dimensionality reduction so what
we're talking about here is we're taking
a set of numeric attributes along
dimensions and we're going to compress
them using a scoring function into a
single numeric value so we have like
this is a 5 mental example of thing gets
compressed into a 58 score so you might
wonder like okay those just seem like
arbitrary values came up with those and
in fact I think that you are entirely
correct to say that may be somewhat
controversially I don't believe that
there's any such thing as a correct
scoring function so if we use the
example of walkscore there's no reason
you couldn't create a walkscore where
every single address got 100 and you can
also create a walkscore where every
single address if it's zero those are
totally valid scores but nobody would
use your system so in my view kind of
it's only the public recognition by
acclamation that you the domain expert
are properly scoring something that
allows scores to be accepted and as kind
of evidence of this theory ESPN has
released a
rating metric to score quarterbacks that
has been less well received than the NFL
scoring metric so they both purport to
score you know the disposition in
football but people accept the NFL score
more than ESPN score so in there's no
one right score or one way to do things
there's no correct way to score
something it's does the public except
the expertise that went into creating
that score so ok say you sat down today
and you wanted to make a scoring
function how would you do it right now
you would use the dual approach and so
I'm going to use some terminology from
like linear programming or optimization
so in the dual approach what you're
going to do is you're going to start by
selecting a set of basis functions
that's these phii's so let's say we were
rebuilding walk score well we might want
some kind of radial drop off function
that is the distance away from school or
the distance away from a grocery store
so we're going to come up with these
functions the experts just going to
think these up and then the experts
going to twiddle with the coefficients
associated with these functions until
things look more or less correct so we
have the set of coefficients that wheat
will and the set of basis functions that
the expert kind of comes up with so the
problem with dual scores is that they
ossify so you quickly are very quick to
develop but then you also get an estate
where if you try to fix a mistake you
end up creating more mistakes than you
fix which means that you just end up not
you just stop touching the score
entirely so I'm going to rag on
walkscore a little bit which is totally
unfair their CTO actually responded to a
cold email i said i'm at like I went up
to Seattle and met with them and like
learn all about scoring in their system
and how it worked and they're really
great guys but he would actually be the
first to admit that their scoring system
is not fantastic so for instance this is
a market sixth Street which everyone
the city would be familiar with and walk
score identifies this is a walkers
paradise which may be um okay so so
what's happening here well I actually
literally brought up this example 2
lakhs for CTO and he's like yeah we
don't like why doesn't crime play a role
in the score and he said well we don't
really mess with it anymore because we
found out when we start messing with it
it breaks other stuff so it just got it
is what it is so that's like not a great
solution and when I was thinking about
screwing systems that answer really
inspired me to create something that
could actually get better over time as
opposed to just kind of doing this so I
came up with supervised scoring which is
a in contrast to the dual approach from
the optimization side can be considered
a primal approach because instead of
dealing with these kind of dual basis
functions you deal directly with objects
and their scores so in supervised
scoring you start by labeling a
reference set of you know kind of
candidate values so you say I think this
thing should get a 50 and this thing she
go to 65 and the dimensions of the
objects themselves you say this is a
good attribute this is a bad attribute
this is a good attribute and then an
algorithm makes a scoring function that
interpolates your 3d reference set and
also obeys your monotone relationship so
there are some really good features of
the supervised scoring system that you
don't see with the dual approach so the
first one is this guarantee of
monotonicity the way you'd expect it to
do and this goes back to my larger
philosophy outscoring functions that if
the only reason you're scoring function
is credible is that people believe the
score is coming out of it you don't want
a system where increasing a bad
attribute makes the scores go up which
can and will happen if your scores don't
have a guarantee of modernity so this
goes back to the idea that it's up to
people to accept and understand the
score that the expert is imposing on
and if the expert knows that you know
certain that certain dimensions are bad
and other dimensions are good like
crying as bad and distance to a school
is I guess it would also be bad because
it would be a decreasing score in
distance if that's not reflected in the
scoring function but the experts
creating people won't believe the score
is in a won't get traction the second
and more important feature I think of
supervised scoring is that it's very
very easy to improve the score so
imagine that you have seen a Miss scored
point like sixth and market gets a 100
you can add it to the reference set with
a correct score say 50 and then just
rerun the algorithm and then you're
guaranteed first off that because the
algorithm interpolates that six the
market will get a score of 50 but you're
also guaranteed that every other member
of the reference set will have exactly
the same score as when you start with it
so just to go back to kind of a LP
optimization idea this is kind of like a
row generation idea so we keep adding or
maybe for a software engineering
perspective this is kind of like
regression testing right we find things
that break and then we throw them into
the unit testing framework and then we
can be sure that they'll never break
again right other stuff can break and
we'll invent new tests to make those
things not break as well but the nice
thing is that we can be assured that we
will never see a failure on something
that had that we've seen a failure on in
the past once we fix it so it's these
two features the monotonicity which can
help with acceptance and then this row
generation or regression testing
property of the reference set that
really makes scores that will like
there's a very easy path for them to get
better over time but they certainly
won't get worse over time okay so I
swept something under the rug which was
the word algorithm that does all this
magic you know there's there's a
there's a scene in the matrix where
Morpheus talks to me oh and he's
explaining the nature of the real world
out there in the cornfields where people
are hooked up to bat and he just has
this like real throwaway line that says
like you know combined with a source of
fusion the machines that all the power
they'd ever need and that's just kind of
like totally just not even discuss for
the rest of the film and my impression
is like what's the source of fusion like
what are we going to hear about that or
like that seems like why do they need
the human brands and similarly like I've
just totally skipped over this part of
the algorithm that does all this magic
which is really the fundamental part so
okay let's talk about calc in the
algorithm so one of the very interesting
research features of this problem is
that I have never encountered a problem
that is so easy in a single dimension
and so freaking difficult in multiple
dimensions so how easy is it in one
dimension well it's really easy so
here's a set of monotone increasing
points and I want to move at an
algorithm that interpolates at obeys
amount of Missy so I can just do
piecewise linear that works I can also
do something fancier like spines cool
pretty much any like lying that you draw
that goes up into the right it's all
those points as long as your algorithm
does that it will be fine in one
dimension so that's really great you're
like oh this is like an easy problem
like no issue and then it turns out to
be hard in many dimensions I don't
really have a formal proof I mean
there's some like maybe and B hardness
stuff you could think about in here but
it's hard from the sense of light I
tried a bunch of different approaches to
get this working and none of them worked
for a very very long time and since I
have the time tonight I'll just
introduce some of those failed
approaches because I think in general
people I've attend see to talk about the
stuff that's successful and they never
really talked about some that didn't
work so I'm going to talk about some
stuff that didn't work that our baby
clever ideas but failed so the first and
maybe most obvious one is a simple
interpolation which is can just be
thought of as a
multi-dimensional piecewise linear
routine and in fact there's like I think
it's a sci-fi library that just does
this for you just hand it a bunch of
points and you say interpolate these
that it will give you a function
unfortunately that function is not
monotone this is my demonstration
example here so I have four labeled
points in two dimensions the 195 95 and
then five so the monitor relationship I
want is that when I move to the south or
to the west the score should go up and
for the left-hand interpolating triangle
it doesn't have that because as I move
to the west across that triangle the
point that's labeled five gets more
weight and the point that's labeled 95
gets less weight so the score goes down
and there is not a really easier elegant
way to fix this idea okay so maybe we
can try some other stuff here's an
approach that doesn't actually really
work but I still got a paper out of it
you supplied product basis as featured
in triple-a I 2014 produced these really
beautiful scoring functions that can
interpolate through things unfortunately
they don't really scale the more than
two dimensions and they don't schedule
or in two dimensions because of the
curse of dimensionality so if you're not
familiar with recursive mentality it
generally suggests that whatever you
have is exponentially blows up and the
number of dimensions that you're working
with so here's a graphical picture so
like in one dimension you're like oh
that's like that's not hard i just need
to solve for like five coefficients in
my program it's like two dimensions that
was like 25 like that we didn't like 30
so that's like the curse of nationality
and it totally trips up this technique
unfortunately the triple AI reviewers
did not pick up on that so right a
another approach that is fairly natural
would be radial basis functions which
you may have used in an SVM at some
point so this was a very clever idea
that Kenjon Stanford came up with very
quickly when I started working with them
his idea was okay just use these radial
basis functions there's no guarantee of
authenticity with the radial basis
functions but we can use row generation
to check modernistic so essentially we
all solve this problem that make sure we
interpolate then we'll somehow generate
cleverly a set of points at which to
evaluate monotonicity if we fail
monotonicity we'll just add those as
rows into a program and rerun and keep
doing this until we can test a bunch of
points and it's all Monaco direction we
want and it works well so this doesn't
work either because it also suffers from
the curse of nationality so you know you
can think about in four dimensions you
have to test you know in a sort of end
times more points than you would in
three dimensions so it also suffers this
exponential blow-up and what this kind
of failure taught me is that if you want
monotonicity your scoring function you
have to have it guaranteed from first
principles it's not something that you
can just kind of build in later which is
what this approach is trying to do it's
a pretty clever approach but doesn't
work so i tried neural networks and you
know i was going to desperate when i
tried neural networks sorry I religious
thing um okay so actually you know
neural networks unlike most problems
it's actually a really natural fit here
because the essentially you know you
think about a typical response function
like logistic function and is monotone
okay that's pretty cool and then as long
as our weights of combining as logistic
functions are positive which we can just
make make that happen then the resulting
function and the next layer will also be
monotone so it's a great way to
guarantee mommy misty and there's a
theoretical result that says as long as
we have rightness
so in general neural networks are kind
of universal proxima ters because these
are monotone we need to have a second
like we need to have two hidden layers
and so if just one to get to the output
that we need and it should still be
universal though and there's proof and
in fact there's even an r package that
does this monotone multi-layer
perceptron neural networks Mon MLP you
can download and use it it just
unfortunately doesn't seem to run
practice I gave it a test example and i
ran for really really really long time
and then kind of spin out a man sir that
wasn't right and that just reinforced my
just general perception of neural
networks okay so finally we had success
and i came from this obscure paper that
was titled wouldn't suggest that it
would be successful i was published
about ten years ago in like di t
numerical mathematics and it's called
Mon ethnicity preserving approximation
of multivariate scattered data of course
we're not trying to approximate
scattered data but whatever this worked
really well and if the x value cobb so
it's i'm going to call this the Belyakov
technique i'm going to describe what it
does in order to do that after you do
some boring math stuff so as a reminder
there's this notion that's a strong
notion of continuity called Lynch its
continuity and what it means is that
your function values are less than some
constant times the difference in where
you evaluated that function or
graphically which is the right way maybe
the easiest way to think about it it
means that your function entirely exists
within these cones that are projecting
those cones that I drew should go to
infinity but they would like just
obscure the screen so just imagine those
cones which I can to affinity and if you
have it if your function is literate
continuous you know that every value
will fall within those cones there Matt
you're
function will never go outside those
cones if you have a monotone function
the shape of your cones changes in
monotone Lipschitz continuity and you
get these like flat triangle cones
instead of those like two sided cones
because obviously you know function
can't go down if it goes to the right
they can't go up if it goes to the left
from that point does everyone follow the
cone argument okay cool so what is the
value cop technique so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to get
we assume that it has this Lipschitz
parameter which we can actually solve
for given the input data we're going to
project these monotone Lipschitz cones
from each point to generate upper and
lower bounds and then we're going to
take the soup which is the lowest the
smallest upper bound and the int the
highest lower bound from these bounding
cones so we get a range of values that
our function needs to be between and
then we just pick the value that's
halfway in between those two bounds and
it seems like really simple and it
actually works and it works really well
even a bunch of dimensions so this is an
example for abelian Cobbs paper the
cones kind of don't look like cones here
because he's really um chop them off but
you can see that the as a result you can
see how that cones converge around any
point that you've given in the reference
set so that guarantees interpolation you
can just cut it's a very like easy
mathematical argument to see that the
soup and inch pounds will themselves be
monotone in the direction you want which
means that halfway in between them will
be monotone and the way you want which
means your functional we got a ton of
the way you want so it's kind of a
frankly a very elegant application of
Lipschitz continuity and there's only
one problem with this in practice and
that's that it's a little bit too
aggressive about these function values
so the thing about Lipschitz continuity
is that it's not it's it's it's far too
loose for a number of your points right
you're saying that well okay what if the
function is you know maybe in a local
area is like relatively you know not
really it doesn't need this giant
Lipschitz constant in order to get all
the function values so as a result you
unfortunately get these plateau where
the upper the soup bound and the int
found don't change as you kind of move a
pencil across the function and as a
result the because your soup down to say
in the same you're in found is saying
the same halfway between them is staying
the same which means your function value
stays the same and you get these flat
areas so this is kind of like a boring
way but I actually have a nice
demonstration of this so this is what if
you have if you had it like a
demonstration scoring problem with a
bunch of labelled points what you end up
getting looks like a series of like
almost like a Mario level or something
like a platform thing where you get
these very steep jumps in between these
like rather large flat areas so all
right can we smooth this out and the
answer is yes so we're going to stop
using Lipschitz continuity because it's
like a math thing and we're applied math
people and we're just going to project
these minimal cones from each point what
do I mean by minimal cones I'll just
show you a picture right this is the
value cough Lipschitz cones and those
are minimal cones so essentially like
every function value falls in between
those cones and so the nice thing you
see is that right unlike the monotone
Lipschitz cones they're not really flat
ever unless they have to be which means
the functions never flat and indeed if
you run a similar example you get a much
smoother by interpolating surface which
is pretty elegant so this is what high
score does this is the high score
technique so it's a modification of the
value cup technique to be more usable in
practice and one of the nice things here
is that pretty much everywhere this
function if you move up
in the score increasing direction you
actually will see an increase in score
it's it's very very disinclined from
ever being flat which is again very
important if you go back to the original
theory of what scores are because it
provides validity and external
validation to the fact that your score
is working because hey I just increased
a good thing and now my score went up as
opposed to I increased a good thing am I
supposed to exactly the same so I'm
going to give an example of how you can
use high score and it's going to be a
simplified water well score whereas the
Syrian so the world health so this is a
watermelon Tanzania I was actually
informed in this example I gave a talk
on a very early version of this work at
IBM Research Africa in Nairobi and they
had the talk people were like can we use
this to like score traffic intersections
I roby can we use this to score water
wells in Tanzania and I was like cool
yeah absolutely so this is like what a
water well in pans Neil looks like so
it's a certain distance from structures
and has a certain platform sighs and
there's actually a World Health
Organization metric which is just ten
yes or no questions about the water well
so they've asked questions like is there
a ditcher pond within 10 meters of the
well and you want a no answer not a yes
answer so the risk of contamination the
water wells increases with the number of
ETS answers so this is a kind of an
existing scoring system and for this
example I'll just use a very simplified
version which only has two factors but
we're going to use numeric factors
instead of binary factors so we'll just
say I'm distance for the nearest latrine
and platform size so the first thing we
need to do for using supervised scoring
is we have to label a reference set and
what I found is is that one of the
quickest ways to get the sort of
nonlinear responses you want out of your
system is to just take a high middle and
low value in each dimension so for
distance from latrine will say well a
low value is 0 meters a median value is
10 meters that's the value that the
Joe uses and then 50 meters is a large
distance and then for platform size will
use like one square foot right 25 square
feet 5 by 5 and 100 square feet 10 by 10
where again 25 square feet is what the
wh 0 uses as the binary threshold so I
being an expert in water wells scored
this reference set and label the
monotone relationship as increasing in
both dimensions right we want the score
to go up the further from latrine you
are we want the score to go up as your
platform size increases and this is as
close as I'm going to come actually
doing a live demo of high score we can
hi thon we can just import high score we
can set the reference set which is going
to be addicting tuples to numeric values
we set the monitored relationship vector
and then we just call high scorer create
on the reference set and as additional
information we can tell it a the minimum
value ever wanted to send out and the
maximum value we ever wanted to send out
and what you get when you calculate
values using the object that's created
by this call is this cool nonlinear 3d
plot and you know you could verify that
this actually does interpolate through
the points that you handed it and it
obeys the monotone relationship and
another thing is it kind of picks up on
some of the nonlinearities that you
expressed in the reference set scoring
so essentially you know that you're
valuing distance from latrine more than
size of the water well so you can kind
of see that reflecting the scores it's a
little bit it's hard because the three
dimensions but yeah so that that's kind
of the output of this function this is
kind of elegant nonlinear function so we
can also make this model more complex
like okay there are things you want to
score that aren't just two dimensions so
what if we want to add more dimensions
so one way to do that would just be to
go ahead and add dimensions but a clever
way of doing it is to avoid the curse of
dimensionality by building a tree so say
I wanted to add distance to other
pollutants that
latrines and then I wanted to add a
feature to say is my platform damaged or
not so instead of having a single score
with these four inputs I can actually do
three different scores with two inputs
where the location score here and the
platform score r sub scores and then the
overall water well score is actually a
high score object created from the
output of other high score objects so in
this way we're only labeling instead of
labeling you know whatever 3 to the 4
values we only have to label 3 squared
values three times but the nice thing is
that this can then scale you know is
obviously toy example but using this a
tree and subscore method you can build
and more importantly understand by
looking at the sub scores as the values
percolate up tree scores with dozens of
input dimensions so one of the companies
that I work with is independent energy
standards and they do this for fracking
wells and their score has dozens of
dimensions that gauge you know how safe
is fracking well is so that's and they
are using this tree based method to
express that score and frankly it's very
difficult to even kind of think about
scores that have set a dimensions right
you can't put 17 mentions your head I
had a professor at CMU the clanky the
most legends he visualized was ten sure
but you know it's very difficult to
actually get a sense of what's happening
with 70 input dimensions but I would
suggest that a combination of high score
which guarantees these nice mounted
nisti properties plus you know this tree
structure actually gives you the ability
to more or less make sense out of a
score with 70 input dimensions which
frankly is a lot better than what club
did okay and just in closing um you
might suggest like one of the obvious
kind of complaints about technique like
this as well what if my inputs aren't
monotone you know what if you
I want a middle value in the middle
value is the best not a low value or a
high value so an illustration of this is
blood pressure so there are two numbers
that come up in blood pressure systolic
and diastolic systolic is your blood
pressure where your heart is beating and
the other is where your heart is at rest
and there's this normal range that's
good if you're above the normal range
that's bad and then if you're kind of
have low blood pressure that's not
better it's like kind of bad ideally
you'd have some way of expressing this
than high scores so this would be right
these are two non monotone input
dimensions okay can we use high score
this and the answer is yes we can
convert this problem from to non Monaco
dimensions into for Monaco dimensions
right so we change a single value of
systolic blood pressure into a like a
systolic plus at a systolic minus and we
let the function be decreasing in both
of these values and we set one of these
values to 0 depending on which side of
the you know if you have high or low
blood pressure and so in this way we've
turned a problem with two non Monaco
dimensions into four monotone metrons
and then we could use high score to
produce a really good score on this
because you know you can see it's going
to be nonlinear we want to pick up it
kind of these diastolic minus in
systolic minus variables are not as bad
as their plus equivalents and high score
could pick that up based on labeling the
reference set so this is available it's
open source that's my first open source
packages I was joking earlier that uh
this is a lot better code that I
normally right I've never actually
released an open source package a little
bit like walking around like kind of
like going outside naked so I definitely
like put a lot more effort into the code
it has like tests and like really good
comments and stuff which is not normal
like a lot of feedback for people
set the initial release to it early did
you write this code this looks a lot
better than code you're right uh yes um
and it's on I don't know actually the
Python package index I don't want to say
pi PI because that means something else
but you can install it with pit you just
do pip install high score and it will
install your computer's you can mess
around with it so whatever you want to
score is out there so go get to it thank
you very much